[Musique]
de pass je mesure le
temp musalement parl une étonnante
maturité voici Benjamin Biolet
connaisszvadori qui je ve changer
d'atmosphère dans mon jardin d'hiver un
surdoué l'fance
àour à
chanter violon pour
[Musique]
mettre j'avis envie moi ai de donner ma
vision de mes chansons moment c'est pas
de la vraie frustration on ressent le
besoin
quandmeexprimer soêmeend tellement
travers des Ares que plus simple une
voix sur le
[Musique]
fil et un style le
splin violon nostalgique piano
neurastque à symphonique sur des textes
joliment de la part
des vous savez il y a des
artistes on se sent un petit peu sur la
même longueur d'onde parce que ils sont
dans le registre du
de la mélancolie et aussi de la de la
bonne de la bonne mélodie et du bon
[Musique]
texte amour
desés prison de mélancolque alors pour
le prier contact avec le public benam du
plus bienveillant des parents pourquoi
parce que j'aime bien ce qu'il fait
parce que je trouve que il est un
chanteur chic qui fait des chansons
ch
[Musique]